[Music]
[Applause]
be-caw reality
[Music]
[Applause]
what is going on everybody thank you for
coming out all right we're all settled
in I'm excited to be here been here all
day this town I did the whole town which
means I went to the pizza place
gotta love Bucks County man the quaint
little coffee shops I was at a coffee
shop today
one person bathroom that's what we got
going now everyone was complaining about
you know men's and women's and
identifying now we just have one person
bathrooms that we all just gotta wait
when someone's in the bathroom when
you're waiting how long are you expected
to wait before you can knock and say are
you dead in there without being the
[ __ ] for doing that right look I gave
a little knock once going here all right
then the guy goes go over there now why
don't you give him a minute okay I gave
him 27 minutes man could watch the
sitcom what are they doing transcribing
the Koran yeah
this is my move now whenever I get up to
a bathroom even though I know it's
already occupied I do a hard jiggle on
the handle and they inevitably always go
something to him and then I go oh I'm
sorry but in my head I'm thinking and
now you know somebody's on him let's put
this into overdrive alright and if they
still take too long my next move is I
jiggle it again but I pretend I'm
somebody else right
and in my original character I say to
the second jiggler I go yeah no I'm
actually next there's a line meeting
going on on the other side we come out
just me looking both ways yeah everybody
else died of septic shock
it's nice to be out right getting some
Lance a lot of dissension in this
country right now don't worry I don't
get political we don't have to worry
about that but whatever is going on in
this country it's all a deal you know I
just don't like one far and it's not
interjecting I was doing a gig in
Toronto I got a couple buddies in a
Canadian we're doing a few shows
together having a couple drinks
afterwards one of my buddies goes yeah
you're president Trump I wouldn't want
to have him run at all country oh I
couldn't even bite my tongue I'm like
proud I don't even know who your guy is
want to put this in perspective all
right in your country by the way my guy
is in Georgia your country too don't
tell yourself don't treat yourself what
kid yourself are you kidding me I love
the Canadians but let's be honest 80% of
the entire Canadian population lives
within 50 miles of the American border
and in this famine I'm saying they're
hovering over the velvet ropes
[Applause]
Aladar deficit I don't know if you read
about this 22 trillion right the deficit
apparently they were talking about
selling Montana pay off the deficit like
why don't we just take my salary this is
this is that deficits up to twenty two
trillion man we go China again I don't
your political but people get my face
with it they're like China holds us get
ready china owns us I'm here to tell you
don't even worry about it it doesn't
matter because we're not [ __ ] paying
them back I mean that's one of those
it's a jokes but it's not a joke joke
chip away at twenty two trillion night
trip oh you just wake up one day and say
you know what's gracious I'm not paying
anybody yeah you thought you got to do
all you do it I got a door hey I don't
have to a puzzle run for president I go
I get rid of deficit my first day in
office everybody how would he do that I
wouldn't tell him ago you gotta vote for
me baby I'm gonna tell you spit the
wheel
can he do it take him maybe enough
people getting that voting booth and
they see your name they're like let's
give it a shot quick my first day in
office I'll just show that building in
New York City wait you see I have the
deficit up on the wall the building it
just constantly keeps shooting up I just
have a camera and is everybody looking I
just press a button fold 0 there you go
look how your friends spread the word
which I'll be watching on TV going ah
that's gonna be a problem I love this
small-town vibe I live in a small town
upstate New York all Fredonia New York
so yeah it's a lot like this but what
taxes are like one month worth of your
past I can't believe it I move did his
pan it's like an hour outside of Buffalo
long story my wife is from the area my
first move day I was at Main Street with
a buddy we're going to have a couple
beers I didn't feed the meter
and he goes I go is that gonna be a
problem he goes well if you don't mind
getting Jack seven dollars that's the
boy when I see the meter I'm like I'm
gonna keep it here monthly bro
[Applause]
New York City in 22 years that's a cup
of coffee yeah everyone's employed by
the factory to think if the factory
shuts down we'll have to move my story's
a little different if belper shuts down
I gotta move that's how I fly out of
Buffalo Delta 20 prefer to align Delta
serves peanuts pretzels and cookies
if you flied out that you would know
that because they say it to every single
passenger it's a little bizarre man but
there'll be three in a row whole peanuts
pretzels cookies cookies pass me twice
I'm gonna think I'm sitting there going
you better ask me I want to sue my hurt
that [ __ ] don't assume I did [ __ ]
Stampede out the room man I feel bad for
the fly a penance I just be laying in
bed in their own home the husband's like
good morning baby baby yo yo baby
you drinking man you got a drink on me
no my Broadway play got the drink that
stared at me like you're waiting for me
to break into a fellow or something even
I'm drinking it up who fooling guy you
know they aligned snacks we can't get
enough of them right huh
I fly early that's my thing I always fly
early if there's a problem you got time
to fix it I fly so early I got to the
gate once coffeeshops not even open yet
she's me and a guy about my age and he's
in a wheelchair and we're both waiting
to get coffee now he gets a phone call
coffee shop opens I figure let me treat
the guy right I come back I give him the
coffee he thanks me introduces himself
and we shake hands now no sooner do we
finish shaking hands the guy
[Music]
I'm considering I just physically shook
his hand as you could imagine my first
thought was I think I just healed this
guy I don't even call this do we call
the Pope what do we do right why not
wash the head then he sees the stud look
in my eye and he goes all know I work
for the airport pushing people in the
plane's game and I just got in early you
know the wheelchair you can walk by the
way you wiggling in what's that my next
thought this guy was me 250 for the
coffee with those airline snacks Frankie
I fly a gun on Flint I get like 5 a.m.
flight and you just hear like all these
little styrofoam bags everyone trying to
open up the pretzels 5:00 a.m. right if
you're in your own kitchen at 5:00 a.m.
and you opened up a cabinet it's sort of
pretzels you wouldn't eat them what are
we doing
I've had a flight once 5:30 in the
morning flight attendant comes on tells
us they're out of pretzels they're not
going to be serving pretzels and a guy
sitting right next to me mumbles to
himself out loud he goes god damn it
what is this guy's like Delta just for
freshness never see people put the
airline snacks in they're bad for later
oh my my trash they even play out man
okay you run your couch at home and your
wife's like I'd love a snack the
pretzels baby
I had a flight once 5:30 in the morning
flight attendant comes on tells us
there's a child on board allergic to
peanuts and then they're not going to be
serving peanuts now listen I have a
child too I understand I'm not getting
into all that I'm just saying the minute
you hear it that someone a child is
allergic to peanuts it's just human
nature
it's like Murder on the Orient Express
you're just looking around trying to see
if you can figure out which kid it is I
can't eat the pants it's probably too
red hey it's gotta be the redhead accent
and the pilot comes on ten minutes later
he thanks us again for not eating the
peanuts
I mean it's 5:30 in the morning who's
eating peanuts if the pilot came on and
said there was a child on board allergic
to coffee he'd have been dead by 5:45
peanuts man I mean how allergic is
allergic ask yourself right like if I
opened up a little bag of peanuts all
the way in the front of the plane wreck
if that kid was all the way in the back
right if I'm just like
[Applause]
and just give a little pad just a little
pen like all the sudden you get here in
the back I'm playing just a little
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
piling it's on right I feel like I can
eat the whole bag of peanuts and go up
to the mother at the baggage carousel
just be like swine and only kids
[ __ ] I don't want to sound ignorant
and I know this is ignorant but when
you're not allergic to the thing it's
hard to wrap your head around it right
like if I get stung by a bee nothing
happens to me if I'm with somebody they
get stung by a bee in their head swells
up I feel like they're being lazy I feel
like I could be like beasts well that'd
be swell back it's embarrassing what are
you doing
asparagus is a perfect example right a
lot of people eat asparagus later on you
pee that night and it smells like
asparagus I never happened to me I
thought it was witchcraft been in my
late 30s I must have had a chemical
change in my body I had a little
asparagus one night later that night I'm
out of bar I'm in the bathroom peeing
next to a friend of my friends like Oh
not even a hitman
it smelled like I was boiling asparagus
420 holy [ __ ] no food eat and then piss
and it smells like I'm never gonna be
the bathroom with your buddy going what
is that
oh we didn't eat the peanuts flying is
stressful let's complain it to my
brother he goes you got to go Southwest
man that's my airline Southwest you pick
your own seat froze you might not know
when you're walking down the aisle of a
Southwest airline you can sit whatever
you want so gave it a shot
it's too much pressure I would rather
just be assigned the seat because all
you want to do is sit next to a normal
person that's your goal at the end of
the day you fly Southwest you literally
stout in' before you get on you see if
people get on before you and you're
making notes like oh don't go next to
that guy I can help out a vest he takes
his shoes off halfway through the flight
mental note mental note avoid that one
oh we got a dog we got a dog coming on
forget then that's the thing cause you
got to decide you got a split second
when you get on the Southwest flight
you're walking down there's a line of
people in front of you and you got to
walk and you got to make a quick
judgment and once you pass someone
there's no going back there are people
riding in your ass you gotta go like
that one fella then you do a peak down
you like it's the rest of the way but
the guy behind you is like you just stop
it must be a nightmare down there
quicken goes down
[Applause]
my brother says though you've got to pay
a few extra bucks you get on the plane
first and you can sit wherever you want
so I did that round one time too which
works you get on every seats available
very nice problem is these Southwest
flights all sell out so eventually
somebody's gonna be sitting next to you
so now this is a whole different kind of
pressure because now as people are
coming down the aisle depending on what
they look like I'm making myself more or
less appealing to sit next to a guy in a
hunting jacket leaning over I won't even
look at him I'm rubbing my balls my nose
[Applause]
it's like a bear I'm playing tangent
then you get a nice normal lady coming
down the aisle
oh I'm practically lighting candles I
got incense going I'm like I do nails
halfway through the flame
let's the thing to you ever see somebody
thinking about sitting next to you and
then they decide not to I'm like mumble
it to the lady actually is going down
the aisle I don't know what you think is
down there lady
I've been down there ain't nothing down
in this wrestle I know right every
aspect of flying is stressful
my wife she gave me this face cream for
my birthday cause $50 a bottle right
away it comes with instructions from her
she's like make it last it's $50
you just need four dimes every night
dime dime dime dime don't flap it on
tonight baby they're gonna go through
airport security oh here we go they
don't want to let me through with the
face cream don't you love to when the
TSA people start giving you suggestions
that like aren't even realistic right
like the lady looks at me and she goes
what do you have a friend that you could
call that would come pick up the face
cream
[Music]
my friends actually doing that for each
other maybe I need new friends I don't
even have a friend that would pick me up
I don't even know how I would make that
phone call with a laugh in my [ __ ]
seriously give a call befriend a friend
you mind driving an hour and 10 minutes
the JFK Airport you pick up my face
crack yeah yeah yeah I'll tell you when
I land a week later you drop that [ __ ]
back off oh you're a peach Brown you're
a peach that's why I Drive whatever
possible
I got a 2006 Subaru Outback been through
a lot together been through a lot
together with the roof
had a recall on the rule recently
apparently the passenger side airbag
could blow up I had to take her in for a
recall my crew and I we've been through
a lot anyone with a vehicle you go you
go through a lot your vehicle becomes
like family ever up the dashboard going
up a hill and really cold weather I have
my Subaru and -3° I'm like you got this
girl the horses recall I've never done
that before I walk in there go no
problem sir we'll take you Carl take
about an hour and a half you just sit
tight have some coffee and we'll let you
know when it's done no sooner do I sit
down attractive lady works the Subaru
comes walking up with a clipboard
because I just want you to know we did a
quick evaluation of your vehicle and
this is what it's currently worth you
know which is nothing and devastating to
here like I didn't ask for this
information and she goes if you want we
could take this and put it towards a new
vehicle and you could be driving out
with one of these beauties in less than
a half-hour now this is just all
happening so fast
so incentive it's my vehicle looking at
it through the window like the - coming
up oh I knew what do you I'm telling you
man I'm only bringing it up cuz it's
happening with cars before you know it's
gonna be happening with us as humans man
give me a negative quadruple bypass
nurse is gonna come out go up to your
life listen before we cut this warhorse
open just want to let you know we've got
three men in their early thirties on the
other side of the wall here dying to
take you out for a steak dinner
I go Valvoline that's my that's my oil
people I go to Valvoline Valvoline they
bring the dipstick into the waiting room
to show you that they filled up your oil
oh how nice is that literally on the
phone my wife he comes walking in I'm
like yeah what'd he say I'm I hold on
baby he's showing me the dipstick this
mr. Cory Ali just want to show you
filled it all the way up right there I'm
like beautiful man thank you very much I
know nothing about cars and show me
completely dry coat I totally drained
all the oil at a car ball dry I go
beautiful get that over the line there
hate that [ __ ]
I was making an appointment with
Valvoline recently to have me on hold
and I had it on speaker I take it to the
limit by the Eagles was playing and my
wife comes walking down the stairs so
it's babbling right away and I go whole
lot about to pick up but she goes oh my
god why do you think that because the
song is ending that means I think
there's a guy in Valvoline hovering over
the phone what the Eagle saw going limit
one more I got a lot of like you people
have around here too
got a lot of the deer crossing signs she
always perplexed me you know Shepherd
driving along you have the woods for ten
miles on either side you don't sin you
get the 11th miles as a sign saying thea
crossing next four miles what about the
last and you didn't even need your son
but the guy gonna put up a sign in the
early angles to get the side Tommy we
don't need a sign but I need a sign
now we got to sit down with the deer
years and years ago we worked it all out
that's the only legitimate way right
like hundreds of years ago did like one
Highway representatives sit down but one
deer representing all the Diaz that's
how long ago this was it was they were
still cool Diaz back then and the
highway guy said that idea if you can
get all the other deer to cross between
exit 42 and exit 43 I think I can get
all my people to slow down let me go
through that area mile to cross over to
come back down a mile to get to the pond
to drink 9 I got to go back to the other
deals with more you gotta give me more
[Laughter]
the highway guy said how about this for
now one when there's more than just one
of you it's still just the end we
dropped the s
only fish have that right now
from the deal went that's hot that's fun
I think I can go back to the other beers
with that you mean you mean the other
that's why we do 55 have you ever tried
to do with sustain 55 like literally
just step on I got a lot of 65 where I
live in New York rate the Thruway I
passed the cop recently let me explain
the situation the cop was doing 65 in a
65 you ever have that then we all line
up behind them here we go
what am i Parade Float what are we doing
right now even giving them that smile
through the windshield a hey hello he's
through 65 put my head on my guy as soon
as you get off I got a do 85 to make up
for the 75 I would normally be doing
right now
maybe even my GPS was going off it was
like
I'm a cop wasn't getting off we kept
passing every exit I'm looking at my
wife like what is he on a road trip with
the cop cop it's out of his jurisdiction
is he stealing it I'm like I got a pass
I got a do to pass that's what I do
whenever I'm gonna break the law in my
vehicle I announce it to everybody else
in the vehicle if I'm gonna make an
illegal u-turn I'm like I'm banging eue
everybody get ready I'm banging aue
they're ready they're ready I don't even
know what that means for everybody else
no I'm not sure I'm just letting you
know about the door violation whatever
you got to do to be comfortable that get
comfortable I mean I say it so clearly
that if a cop pulled me over and I tried
to talk my way out of it I was like oh
I'm sorry I didn't realize I couldn't
make that turn look amigo
I read your lips through the windshield
saying you're gonna bang it you
that's what I did though I slowly passed
the cop I'm doing 70 he's doing 65 never
do that slow five mile an hour pass oh
god your heart is pounding me in PI upon
it's like walking past a pitbull and
your flip-flops I'm just giving the cop
to look through the window the whole
time like are you cool with this give me
a nod give me a smile let me know you're
cool with this right I mean you can't
let me slowly pass you and then you
light me up that's a weak move right at
least give me that to finger wave like
take it back genie
take it back hero look like I apologize
I didn't realize the parade wasn't over
yet
[Music]
that's right they'd though I just slowly
passed them and then you gotta get back
in front of them you like balls and you
just slowly drive off and you know all
the other cause of whispering [ __ ]
so speed limits have gotten the most
intense anyone my age and older and
there's quite a few you out there
no I'm saying no all of us adults and
Beyond come on right remember we were
all growing up people will pass it off
schools at like 45 miles an hour if they
did 50 and a teacher happened to be
outside smoking a cigarette the teacher
might go oh there's kids come on you
pass the school now we got the speed
bombs the flashing lights SWAT teams
hiding in the bushes
my daughter's in candy going at one
point the speed limit in front of her
school goes down to five five okay if
you don't step on the gas pedal the car
those seven I can't even make it to five
I can't do spurts of seven seven stop
seven stop sentence time or I could just
open up the door and put it neutral and
roll the goddamn thing through like the
Flintstones
so I think the school speed limit
passing every school should be directly
correlated to how well the children are
performing at that school right come on
motivation for kids and it helps with
house hunting when you have to know in a
hurry is it a good school district well
they all do an 85 that's the high school
I don't appreciate you coming out cuz
come on let's be out you got a lot today
and now where we live a lot of
entertainment choices
Netflix alone come on why don't we with
Netflix can we pull it down a little bit
with people ranting raving about how
many options Netflix and so much they
have so no Netflix has a lot of [ __ ]
that you have to sift through to get to
the good stuff
movies and Netflix
mate don't take long before you ain't
sniffin a movie star I'm like oh man
there's not even a boldwood brother in a
tease that's why when you get a good
recommendation for Netflix it's like a
drug come home I'm telling my wife are
we gonna do this you sure you want to
watch it apparently we're gonna stay up
late we're gonna blow the Kido off
why don't we I would say rabble we'll
watch one we'll just watch one Frank
that's a problem you try to watch one on
these shows you got Netflix you try to
watch one then you go to bed as you go
to bed the screens like next episode
five four let's see you know it's 4:00
in the morning I'm like no season two
when I get into something man I have to
hear every line like I'm watching a
movie recently the guy leaves the room
he said something but I don't catch it
so turn to my wife and what do you say
she goes I didn't hear it either like
well then why are you asking me so you
don't have to hear every line Pete I'm
like I don't know why he left the room I
don't know what's going on I got a
rewind for all the money Netflix has
they gotta work on the rewind
fast-forward man just trying to go back
a little like alright stop wife yelling
at me going all the way back to the
beginning oh god here we go all the way
back opening credits you know why I
don't think what you think you said Matt
is so much [ __ ] can't believe this
now fast-forwarding oh my god stop stop
josh is yelling I mean here we go we'll
see the whole thing all right here we go
the whole goddamn movie everything
ending credits put something else on now
that we just saw
ten minutes later I'm finally getting it
right where I wanted in my head I'm like
oh man this guy better say something
really now I know he's a prisoner we're
watching a movie recently at one point
the woman turns to the man and goes well
you know what they say behind every
great man is an even greater woman then
my wife pause the movie I knew she would
I knew she would rather I'm on the edge
of the couch you say you hear that
behind every great man there's an even
greater woman I'm like well I am
wallowing away in mediocrity over here
so if I want to step up I'm watching a
movie about two months ago I go to have
my ice cream that's my snack freezer
burn oh you have no idea man it's my
Saturday night so I'm like all hope is
not lost it might just be a top level
you still got to do a deep deep dive
guys I'm sticking a spoon you can hear
all the crystals break it up I'm like
all the way through all the way through
my wife goes well just calm down just
put it back in the freezer we'll return
it tomorrow to the supermarket I'm like
grown men do not return ice cream it's
like well I guess she's just out five
bucks that all right I guess I'll just
have to shoplift $5 worth the [ __ ] next
time we're gonna stick my nose in the
bakery section you know where you get
your doughnuts and you put them in the
white wax bag I got four doughnuts I put
them in the bag I get up to the register
right away ladies how many dollars in
the bank I'm like - you have no idea how
scary that is until it's actually going
down oh my god man I was like I was
trying to get heroin across the border
of my head I'm like ugh I just wipe the
bag lady you swipe the bag swipe the bag
walk it out of my wife is Whisperer and
it's 55 cents of Dorner why would you
even put us in that situation I'm like
this in a freezer brought ice cream
keep walking to block
come around the parking line she's like
what would you have done if they opened
up the bag in soil for doughnuts I go
how would have just been like my wife
wants to put two more doughnuts in there
pay attention I think it's called acting
really I don't know why we're so
enamored with movie stars we act every
day of our lives
[Music]
how many people you go to work you see
someone you don't particularly care for
you're like good to see and like you too
and seem calling in sick for work that's
some of the best acting work we ever do
in our entire lives I was writing on a
sitcom last year I needed a particular
day off yeah not that way you need a
particular day off and you're like I
could ask for that day off but if they
don't give it to me I'm still not gonna
be there that day
so I'm gonna have to go with a call in
sick it's gonna have to call it's a
burden but sideways on you it's on your
own personal calendar I got that today I
got a call in sick that's the day I got
a do my three day acting tolet they for
us cuz when I call and say I don't just
call in sick on the call and sick they I
start acting sick around the office two
days prior to the call in sick day yeah
that like it'll be like a few days
before you're gonna start pretending
you're sick it's the work front that's
gonna hook telling this happened one
time the guy always like we're gonna be
alone on Sunday I was gonna call it sick
Sunday it's just gonna be me and you one
Sunday already took a look at the
schedule we're gonna be getting slammed
so make sure you're ready my head I go
to him you know absolutely man I'll be
ready gonna be double ready you have no
idea how slammed you're gonna be outside
then yeah I just want you to prepare for
the storm I'm [ __ ] cold and sick on
sir that's what I do three days prior to
the call in sick day I just thought
acting a little sick little things a
little coffee here and there normally I
drink coffee but instead I have tea
through a hot dip with the bag until
someone sees and want some let me see
this somebody's like you're drinking
taping I have coffee usually I get
enough something like throw some skunk
down and see what time I was acting sick
throwing to guys like whoa man you sound
bad you should probably go home man to
get getting sick
oh my head I'm like no no I'll be sick
Wednesday I'm fine today Wednesday
Wednesday Pacific
I don't act much why at all really
movies and TV I did a show once and a
director apparently was at the show we
wanted to meet me in the green room like
he's a Fanny oz he's an important guy I
had very little time I couldn't even
google him so I walk him to meet the guy
and he's like hey nice to meet ya nice
to meet you big fan of your work what's
what you say that's what you say your it
says he's like thanks cuz I'm a real big
fan of you and your stuff and he goes do
you do any acting a lot of act like
what's the last thing I may have ever
seen you act in so we said so I just
want to be that guy this room two
minutes ago instead of a fan of your
work
I don't even know who you are and you
put that so what good I got it
I don't think is the accent that's why I
don't really do a lot of acting I don't
why I'm having very thick did you tell
her I mean can you tell him from Kansas
sir
I don't mind over my New York Long
Island accent that is what it is baby
but let's be honest you know the minute
you start talking within this accent
nobody ever thinks oh it is a genius I
wish I could lose the accent sometimes
that's all like my wife and I went to
get a mortgage on the house I had to get
a bank loan before we walk in my wife
goes when we go in there try not to
sound all goombah right away the bank
lady comes up she's like good afternoon
I'm like hey how you doing yeah that's
just to walk away to get something my
wife looks at me how you doin how you
doing pretty order and a pastrami
sandwich at a deli
at the house got the move we got there
we got my five-year-old Thor - man we
moved to the small town start anew in
the small town she's in kindergarten now
any parent knows - no you love when your
kid comes home and act like they've
learned something at school that you
don't know yeah don't get me wrong by
third grade that'll start happening I'm
aware of that but I'd like to think I
would be the valedictorian of
kindergarten but they had a fire neg
come to the school now my daughter comes
home I having dinner and she's like dad
when there's a fire you stop drop and
roll
and she said it with such conviction I
had to be like ya know if it's near you
absolutely but if it's upstairs and
you're downstairs you know then you just
run out no dad you stop drop and roll
now I'm like uh yeah if it's near you my
wife comes guys she's just telling you
what to do again I'm telling hog man
it's the era get just shootin agree with
it agree she's got to know what's the
deal on a fire all the friends are
running out and she's rolling around
like a goddamn pinball
[Applause]
everyone's like one out of the quarry
alleys kids you wouldn't get up like one
of those vacuums that eventually gets
every crevice now more than ever we were
into it with the safety with the kids
rang like I got these two big porches I
get this old Victorian house total money
bit of a house with my daughter and her
friends they'll sit out on the porch
people jog by and they just yell out hi
until the person says hi back
we're neighbors I do think that safe I'm
saying hi everyone oh my god oh god what
do you want me to put chicken wire
around the thing you gotta admit though
right I mean I like I'll see these
headlines where it says attempted child
abduction attempted like they didn't get
it done I don't want to sound crass but
I mean if you can't get a kid into a van
you need to get my daughter into a van a
van that's it
pull up you open up that van the law
she'll be right there what you got man
what you got in it it would be more
difficult to keep her out of the van
give it her a light shove get away from
the van cop would pull up what's going
on I'm trying to drop off a carpet the
kid keeps trying to climb to the cop
dancing
everyone has their own methods dealing
with trying to help goons keep that kids
safe
I got something on Shelley I call it the
inappropriate touch test no cuz that's
my big fear right kids get touched I
taught my daughter if anyone ever
touches you sticks their hand on you but
you stop and yell no Oh mommy daddy run
away we do dry runs around the house
I'll be having coffee my kid walks in
their kitchen I put my hand out a bunch
she goes no no dad and she runs away she
comes back we fist pump blow it up my
wife goes she's got it down come I think
I think I got a runner on a real track
now she's got the drill down right about
wags like she's got it down like she's
got the drill down that's what she's got
that's what you know like and then my
best friend since I was in third grade
him and his wife came to visit last
summer they have no kids spent two days
with us went to the beach one day now
it's the next day he's met my daughter
now for about 24 hours while making
dinner I'm explaining my whole
inappropriate touch test tool of course
he calls me a sick bastard let's get
that out of the way
let go it is on the iPad I go I need you
to go over and just give it a little rub
be perfect right now final a little side
note any parent knows that iPad whoa I
could give my daughter the iPad and I
could go to Miami for the weekend that's
not even an exaggeration so my buddy
goes up and Jessica thrown what up I'll
do it he just gives a light on the back
he's like hey what are you doing sweetie
and she goes back pickles I can walk it
out of que tengo no it's no no mommy
daddy right and she goes no that's all
game dad my buddy goes I think you got a
bigger problem on your hands now bro
that's all I need is my daughter in
school on a rainy day the teachers like
does anyone have any games you play at
home with your family no but it's like
sometimes my dad sticks his hand down my
ass
then we fist bump and blow it out
features like all right everybody heads
down I have to make a quick phone call
pit stop pit stop I don't know I like
where I live though feet Nakia beat
Nicky I got a neighbor who's an artist
and I went to he's a painter I went to
like a show with his paintings and some
others that's a tough racket man I mean
I don't I tell jokes if I tell a joke
and you don't laugh alright I suck
clear my try I've gotta see this guy's
paintings right he's got a beautiful
pink thing with a tree and this and that
there's another one next to his his is
gold for 400 the other ones going for 4
grand I'm like who decides and they're
like there's a curator that like looks
at them and makes a decision
oh if I was a painter and I did the $400
100 right away be like where's the
[ __ ] curator get the curator the
curator I got a tree he's got a tree
he's got a son I got a son who is this
guy that just besides
this curate is right like Picasso
perfect examine everything Picasso paint
was it just automatically a masterpiece
really he would just take the brush call
the Louvre
well Pablo's got another one
Jackson Pollock the drip guy right I
mean are you kidding me
this guy wasn't a good painter he
painted finish the painting and it
wasn't that good and then he looked down
at the floor and said the floor looks
fantastic that's it he did the drippings
I'm not even kidding it was a
documentary where Pollock true story
called his wife from upstairs to come
down after he did his first drip
painting and he said to her is this art
guy if you gotta ask you already got
your answer it's a goddamn drop cloth
everybody start dripping it's a crazy
world that all world they take as long
as they want right you can't tell it
honest how long to take no other job
could you do that I've got a plumber
come in you go how long's this job here
to take you imagine if your plumber in
two days two weeks two months when I
feel it do a negative energy just added
six months to the project I'll tear out
my trailer
Michelangelo took 14 years to paint the
Sistine Chapel 14 years to paint the
ceiling you think that was in the
contract I mean after the third year you
must have been walking in there
whispering like oh god here is it come
with the [ __ ] ladder
this is yelling up what just wanted it
white
please love it you might be dead but
your family there we go that's how D
times really talked over there when
we're not there well let's be honest so
as far as painting the ceiling of a
Chapel everyone anyone whose Catholic
really any religion but I'm Catholic and
we all know churches need to be
aesthetically as beautiful as possible
to get through the owl we need as much
[ __ ] to look at to get through one hour
I just stare at the ceilings I'm like oh
those custom bills
let us more bluntly was that 30 seconds
I just better write this there at the
ceiling you go to church a lot now
because my thought is five my wife
thinks it's important
four o'clock mass every Saturday that's
when we go to church we're gonna take
the funnest date a week and slice that
[ __ ] right in half even in the summer
come on the better church and you can
smell barbecue since [ __ ]
[Music]
we've been at the lake him I'll me and
my daughter in a bundle leg of my wife
for the other guys come on we gotta go
to church I'm running out of water
don't yell that [ __ ] I was in the water
you'd be like [ __ ] it was not doing it
today got a hot game of Marco Polo going
on right here the first time we brought
my daughter to church
I don't shave that often and we walk in
and there's a statue of Jesus with the
beard and she looks up at the statue and
she yells out daddy my wife thinks I'm
Jesus my work is done these priests not
know we can't wait to get out of there
but do they not know have we been so
polite that nobody has ever told them
cuz they show no sign of realizing we
can't wait to get the [ __ ] out of it
it's a basic blows my mind I mean like
you know has anyone ever been to church
but a priest goes church has ended and
seen someone go come on we just want the
bread and they just want the money
that's it
I need the body of Christ especially if
you have a big week it's like a rabbit's
foot good luck
I need the bread I got a lot going on
this week I need the bread
that's the thing when you go to church
at least in my church and you go to get
the body of Christ of bread there's two
lines
what is the priest and another line is
some guy in a Men's Wearhouse so that
was just some dude in a cheap suit and
he's going out the bread - I always tell
my wife don't get the bread from the guy
in the suit it's not as powerful
[Music]
like if you ran a Benihana and you got
the Asian guys slicing up your food then
he walks away to another guy walks up hi
I'm Keith I'm gonna be finishing up here
Keith they need the guy with the pain
it's the whole thing Keith it's the
whole thing
you got any cheap SuJu Selita gal you
later on it's the money churches do it
two different ways some churches do a
basket hand from person to person that's
a little more civil my church does the
stick on the end of the basket
so the guy does the line
and if you don't put in he eyes balls
you for two more lunges let's just I'll
be back for you I come back two more
times
[Laughter]
these priests don't think no we would go
to church more often if they would show
it need man I cursed in church less
Christmas Eve
I literally cursed that walk they knew
it's a full choir that's not normally
there I see the whole choir and I go our
[ __ ] goes why you don't like the music
go no I like the music if it's gonna
take away from the priest walk time but
if the music is gonna be packed on to
the entire mass then shut the music down
man shut it down you know if I was a
priest I would do that it's a little
gift to my parishioners every once in a
while I would have a really short Mass
and you never know what it was coming
that's what we're making so exciting man
just be driving to church I hope it's
one of the short one I'm talking super
short man I'm talking five minutes
before Church thoughts I'm looking at
the altar boy and the organ guy I'm like
start up the organ get the bread ready
soon as I come in we're going right into
the brain soon as you walk in the priest
is like this is the body twice
everyone's like holy [ __ ] keep your
coats on we're gonna be out of here in
five minutes
[Applause]
I do a drive-by with the bread once a
week like a bank every Wednesday 5:00 to
7:00 you just pull up the whole family
in a call and can you go to a Rite Aid
for drugs the priest I just get on to my
company got in a call for give me full
pieces of bread I just handed her to
call I bless the whole cop over there
you go
I ended up in a graveyard with my
daughter we had a cool tie this one or a
three bike ride I had my daughter on the
back of a little trailer hitch thing and
my wife was on another bike my daughter
fell asleep and then I got a flat tire
so I told my wife all right I'll undo
this you take the bike back I'm gonna
take her she's still sleeping I'll walk
her through this old graveyard I'll meet
ya at the hell in the old cemetery my
daughter is still sleeping I got her
this little back trailer thing on the
bike and then we get in the cemetery and
I'm waiting for my wife and I'm leaving
against a tree and my daughter wakes up
now when she fell asleep she was on the
back of a bike now there's no bike no
mom this is the middle of an old
cemetery with big giant angel statues
how'd you see that bad sitting against
the tree ten yards away
I couldn't resist man I just looked at
or I'm like we died
this is where you go and you wait for
Jesus my wife comes walking up hey guys
[Music]
what the [ __ ] wrong with you what's
wrong with you person in a cemetery get
it together
oh I like the small-town living though
certain aspects others like I got a
mouse I had a mouse recently oh boy you
don't even see the mouse at first that
can't be the only one right yeah ever
like like we come down I see that I see
the little mouse droppings on the
kitchen counter there away I'm in denial
I'm looking at my wife and leg did you
have a bagel and you know it's not poppy
seeds you know it's not I just say it in
but in my snow dish [ __ ] everywhere
I always wonder right I do you think the
mice are ever looking through the hole
watching us set up the trap to like bet
this setting up the trap again had a
hell they know we're out there you know
the mouse was like cuz she's [ __ ]
everywhere felt grace won't you just
leave a goddamn map let me I don't even
know I'm doing that I need one of those
things that the horses have in Central
Park
that's what we do we set the metal trap
we put a little peanut butter on the end
of it I'm talking ten days straight I
wake up peanut butter gone traps not
snap back so I got to go to my local
hardware store I go see Tommy with it ee
let's me tells you when you meet him
he's like it's time he would a double
evening wasn't gonna send you a
Christmas card but good to know
I told him my situation he said the
traps not snapping because my mouse was
too light which was a little hard to
understand considering the mouse have
gone through a jar and a half of Skippy
peanut on it you would think it would be
a little caught up at this point must be
on a little treadmill in between a sheet
rock hanging out three miles a day says
they got to put down a glue trap now I
don't know anyone this room has ever
used a glue trap to catch to catch a
mouse knows these glue traps need to
come with a little warning sign that
says are you emotionally prepared to see
this through
do you understand like it needs to come
with a diagram on the back showing a
mouse wiggling did you just don't think
about I come down the next one and I see
something I'm like yelling oh my wife
it's alive my wife comes in with both
looking at it wiggle and she said oh my
god we have to help it that's what you
sagol well I mean technically we're
trying to kill it that's what you mean
right
but help you mean kill it quickly is
that what you mean then she goes let's
fill up the sink and then we'll dunk it
in the water in the sink I'm like you
want a water board the mouse
let's go stop the hell with this and she
grabs a knife added a bunch of blood
I've been married almost 20 years the
entire time I thought my wife was polish
in this exact moment I'm like Otis broad
is Russian she's been lying man then she
turns the knife to the dull side presses
it against the mouse's neck and would
have free fingers she pets it's more
than I signed up for
on a Wednesday man a couple days later
I'm back in the hardware store I see
Tommy would've EE it's like you get a
mouse in my head we got one it's like
how do you know there's not more I'm
like bro even if there were more once
they all witness the execution there's
no more mice in Fredonia buried my dog
we had a dog we had to bury in our
backyard illegally we go out now every
Christmas Eve we start our tradition we
light a candle we sing a few Christmas
carols by the dog's grave my father
heard me say that to Randy goes when I
die even come to my grave every
Christmas even light a candle I go if
you buried behind my girl all I share
let's not forget the convenience factor
going on here
a Christmas tradition my wife loves
Christmas this past summer she goes she
literally goes we have to start thinking
about our Christmas card because we
always make us a funny Christmas card
and she's like it's gonna be cold before
you know and winter's coming I'm like
listen we got a thought thinking about a
new roof prioritize what a hack at this
old Victorian house my roof was such a
nightmare that whenever there was like
any kind of a windstorm my roof shingles
would end up in my neighbor's yards like
my one neighbor came over one day with
all my roof shingles in a bundle Kevin
my neighbor Kevin's like just this all
fell in my yard I just want to bring you
back the roof shingles hey leaves on my
wife goes that was so considerate of
Kevin I'm like considerate that was
Kevin's way of saying fix your
white-trash piece of [ __ ] to his wife
right now going yeah I drop the shingles
right on a [ __ ] porch if they didn't
get the message now they never will so I
called three different roofers to come
take a look at my roof it's got three
different levels as old Victorian I'm
not kidding you every one of these
roofers in one form or another said my
roof was too high like Alaska I didn't
even get out of the truck he just looks
up and it goes aw yeah and I don't go
that high I say I don't I called you
like if the robos down here I wouldn't
need you I would do it myself or I would
cool
I would be like an exterminator coming
at a basement call oh those are big bugs
that do to little bugs gotta call the
big bug I got a call big bug guy I
literally didn't know what I was gonna
do right but my father-in-law tells me
that he knows an old-time Amish guy that
used to do roofs and he doesn't know if
this guy still does roofs but he's got a
phone number and he said that when you
call you gotta let the phone ring for a
long time they got one phone on a pole
in the middle of their Amish community
and eventually somebody will come answer
that lived in New York City for 22 years
now my wife and I are calling an Amish
guy it's on like 24 rings my wife goes
anything yet anything yet push it by the
way am I talking and my [ __ ] walking
dead man I'm like you know he picked up
I'm just ignoring them
she goes we're on it God how many rings
are we on I go I'm on 32 rings I don't
know is this a line rings I don't want
to hang up and then talk to a guy who
knows Amish people and he goes you hung
up on 32 rings Oh
56 behind ya the Amish guy answered on
like ring 38 38 rings the Amish guy
answers like this he goes hello like
it's a breezy Sunday afternoon and you
can win it on Ricky - just a Hello
if the 38 rings don't you expect someone
to answer so I tell him my situation it
says he can come take a look at my roof
but you know he can get to the Home
Depot parking lot I got to pick him up
at the Home Depot parking lot
he's the level of Amish where he can't
drive a motorized vehicle but he could
be driven in a motorized vehicle
pretty convenient level of Amish to baby
sounds a little bit like built it over
from where I'm standing sign up for that
[ __ ]
I'd love to that have that being
Catholic right here at a bar for
Doughboy Billy gave me ride home I mean
I Drive myself a [ __ ] Pope and the
new rules and [ __ ] so I hang up right
away my wife goes way to go you didn't
figure out where you're gonna meet him
at the Home Depot I oh well I guess I'll
just have to look for the guy dressed
like a pilgrim like he's gonna be in an
Adidas tracksuit oh yeah you didn't see
you stretch it over there it's in my
2006 Subaru Outback
it's like 72 degrees out but I put the
seat warmers on anyway I turn the
air-conditioning on radio on I'm doing
the wiper fluid any technology I had I
was firing it uh just my subtle way
saying look at all the shape you're
missing out on God what are you doing
it's crazy
telling you if I was driving a Lexus or
BMW by the time I hit my driveway he
would've said I can't take it I quit I'm
not Amish anymore I'm not Amish man when
I'm driving yeah Amish guy - it's like I
could have took him straight home I went
down Main Street even though I didn't
have to go down Main Street
you got an Amish guy to call you that's
like having a deer in the car I just
wanted to see one body to get the balls
right three Rufus Bale on this roof
because it's too high the Amish guy gets
out without skipping a beat he looks up
at my roof when he goes you do have a
ladder that could get me all the way up
then I go no matter the ladder that goes
that high do a ladder that could get me
up to your porch roof I said yeah I got
I got a ladder for that so I get the
ladder he climbs up to my porch roof
right then he leans down he grabs the
ladder pulls it up puts it on the roof
of the porch climbs up to the next level
the ladder like my insurance doesn't
cover his [ __ ] I got a buddy who owns a
car wash in town he lets me throw stuff
and his dumpster from time to time
that's what's going through my head
right now this Amish guy falls off the
roof of wrapping a minute off and I'm
throwing him in the goddamn car wash
coaster he's got no cell phone on him
he's off the grid nobody's gonna know
it's no different than throwing a possum
in the dumpster
Benny gets up to the top level of my
roof and like a billy goat in seconds he
shimmies up to the highest peak of my
roof leans against the chimney and
lights up a corncob pipe I go running
into my wife and like get the camera we
got the Christmas boy we got the
Christmas
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you